SPEAKER: These days, just about
every person in your business
asks questions about your data.
And the faster they can get
answers to those questions,
the more efficiently
they can do their jobs.
Not only can
optimizing SQL queries
keep all your data
consumers happy,
but it can also save you money.
In this video, we're going to
talk through some strategies
for optimizing your
BigQuery queries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our last episode, we
covered query execution,
including several
tools and concepts
that provide the foundation
for many of the optimization
techniques we're
highlighting today.
If you haven't already,
I highly recommend
taking a pause to watch it
before diving into this one.
All right.
Onto the strategies.
One of the most straightforward
ways to optimize a query
is to make sure that you
limit the number of bytes
it needs to scan.
The first thing
you want to do is
ensure you are only selecting
the columns that you really
need.
That means no SELECT *.
Since BigQuery uses
columnar storage,
the data scanned is
proportional to the number
of columns used in the query.
If you want to take a peek at
the first few rows of the data
to get a feel for what
you're working with,
use the Preview Table
feature instead.
The next thing you can do
is leverage partitioning
and clustering to
automatically prune out
data you don't
need in your query,
like we talked about in our
video on BigQuery storage.
This includes leveraging
filters or WHERE
clauses on columns
used to partition
or cluster the table itself.
All right.
So you went over some
strategies for minimizing
the data scanned in the query.
The next thing we can look
closer at is aggregations.
To understand how to
optimize aggregation queries,
let's look at how
BigQuery actually
executes a query that
uses a GROUP BY clause.
First, the data is read
from our storage system,
and GROUP BYs are done
on individual slots.
Then, the results
from each slot are
bucketed using a hash
function, such that data
from the same key ends
up on the same slot.
We often refer to
this as shuffling.
So in this query, all partial
aggregations for the same wiki
title end up in the same slot.
And we can see the shuffle step
happening in the second stage
of the execution details.
Further aggregation occurs,
and the final result
is then passed along
to the last slot,
for which limits the results.
Since this requires a few
different aggregation steps,
GROUP BY queries can be costly.
For this reason,
you want to ensure
that you aggregate as late
and as seldom as possible.
This can come into play for
queries that have sub-SELECTs.
You'll want to move your
aggregation functions up
to the top to avoid multiple
GROUP BY executions.
But there is an exception.
If a table can be
reduced drastically
by aggregating in
preparation for being joined,
then aggregate it early.
Another thing you can do
to avoid using GROUP BYs
is to nest repeated data.
For example, you might
have a transactions table
that has information
about the order,
including the items
that were purchased.
If you use flat
denormalization, you
would have one row
for each ordered item.
Instead, you can create a
repeated column that contains
a list of all the items.
Now if you want to calculate the
number of items in each order,
you can use ARRAY_LENGTH and
avoid doing any GROUP BYs.
Great.
So now you have some
tactics for aggregations.
But what about JOINs?
Let's begin by looking
at how BigQuery executes
different types of JOINs.
If you join two large
tables together,
BigQuery favors what's called
a hash JOIN, or a shuffle JOIN.
Similar to the
aggregation we discussed
before, BigQuery
uses a hash function
to shuffle both the left
and the right tables
so that the matching keys
end up on the same worker,
and then the data can
be joined locally.
On the other hand,
if one of your tables
is small enough
to fit in memory,
it's not necessary to shuffle
large amounts of data.
In a small JOIN,
or broadcast JOIN,
BigQuery simply
sends the small table
to every single node that's
processing the larger table.
Now that you have a feel for
how BigQuery executes joins,
let's consider how
you can make queries
that join multiple tables
as efficient as possible.
First off, you want to make
sure you place the largest
table first in the JOIN query,
followed by the smallest,
and then by decreasing size.
Next, WHERE clauses should be
executed as soon as possible so
that the slots for
forming the JOIN
are working with the
least amount of data.
You also want to make sure we're
using filters on both tables,
like in this example here.
This way, you're ensuring
data you don't need
is being eliminated from
both sides of the JOIN.
Finally, you can cluster
or partition tables
based on common JOIN keys,
because less data is scanned
and the query will
execute faster.
And actually, clustering
improves the efficiency
even more than partitioning.
So keep this in mind
when deciding on how
to structure your tables.
One last way to optimize
queries is by tweaking the way
you do filtering and ordering.
Something you may not
realize is that when
you are using a WHERE
clause, BigQuery
assumes that you have chosen
the best order for your filters,
meaning the first part
of your WHERE clause
should always contain a filter
that will eliminate the most
data.
Next, if you're using
an ORDER BY statement,
you may run into a
Resources Exceeded error.
This is because the final
sorting for your query
must be done on a single slot.
And if you're attempting to
order a very large result set,
the final sorting can
overwhelm the slot
that's processing the data.
One way you can solve this is by
making sure that you use LIMIT,
so that the result set
is easier to manage.
Phew!
OK, we were able to cover
a lot of great techniques
to make your queries
more performant.
More detail on what
we discussed here,
plus even more
optimization levers,
are covered in the links below.
So be sure to check them out.
Thanks for joining us
today, and watch out
for our next episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight."
Oh, and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]